من بلده علين غرب من مدينه رام الله
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري جيفارا
قريبين من المشهد لديك وانت في البيت او
في جوار البيت الذي تم هدمه
المشهد يتحدث عن نفسه سهام وكان زلزال ضرب
المنطقه ولكن هو بالطبع كما ذكرتم عمليه
تفجير خارجي كان يمكن حسب الاهالي هنا
اغلاق المنزل او حتى تدميره بشكل داخلي
وليس التفجير الخارجي بالطبع يرون ايضا ان
ذلك جزء من العقوبات الجماعيه التي تفرضها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اكثر من خمسين
اليه عسكريه تحمل المئات من جنود الاحتلال
جاؤوا الى هنا بعد انتصاف الليل لثماني
ساعات قاموا بوضع المتفجرات هنا في منزل
الشهيد معتز الخواجه الذي اتهم
بتنفيذ عمليه في شارع ديزنجو في مدينه تل
ابيب في اذار مارس الماضي بالطبع جثمان
الش معتز لازال محتجزا لدى قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذا المنزل هو واحد من 11
منزلا هدمتها او فجرتها قواتها الاحتلال
منذ بدايه العام الحالي لذوي الشهداء او
اسرى وفق ما اكدته منظمه اوتشا التابعه
للامم المتحده وكلما ذكرنا المؤسسات
الدوليه تؤكد ان ذلك جزء من العقوبات
الجماعيه هذا المنزل كان ياوي على الاقل
خمسه افراد لم يتضرر فقط المنزل بل
البنايه السكنيه كلها والمنازل المحيطه
وكانت قوات الاحتلال بالطبع قد اخرجت
السكان
من هذه البنايه والبنايات المحيطه ولكنها
بالطبع كلها تضررت لم تكن هنا فقط العمليه
العسكريه ككل ليله وكل فجر يوم قوات
الاحتلال قامت بتنفيذ عمليات اعتقال
واقتحامات حتى اللحظه وفق المؤسسات
الحقوقيه تم اعتق 13 فلسطينيا من مناطق
متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه اما داخل الخط
الاخضر كان هناك ايضا عمليه اخرى للشرطه
الاسرائيليه التي
قامت باقتحام بلد قريه صندله في مرجع بن
عامر وهي داخل الخط الاخضر والقريبه شمال
جنين بالطبع عافت فسادا في كثير من
المنازل واقامه باعتقال عدد من
الفلسطينيين من القريه بحجه الاحتجاجات ضد
قيام مستوطن اسرائيلي بقتل الشاب ديار
العمري قبل شهر بدم بارد قرب قريته صندله
جدار البديري مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا من
بلده ناعلين في مدينه رام الله